democrats overall a few things that i
know this from running
get really excited about the big sexy
races running for
president congress senate yay that's not
even where most of the money is spent or
the action happens so there needs to be
a thought process for the long term
versus just short term reacting to who's
in office right before and then during
obama's presidency
it wasn't very strategic because they
had their superstar
they could just you know throw obama in
a room and raise a million bucks and
that it was like kind of structure
around the the celebrity of politics
um and it brushed over a lot of
um things like the blocking and tackling
that needed to be done which is these
local these city council races the court
seating the coin appointments
we can't always hope for uh you know
obama somebody that walks on water
politically or
or or we have the devil in office like
those
that we seem to be at our best when that
happens but we need to be able to win
the close and the boring and the regular
races too
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks i'm your
co-host zach grauman
today is a tough day now um
i imagine many of you know it's been the
elephant in the room on this podcast for
six months because it was illegal for us
to talk about it but andrew yang ran for
mayor of new york city
um and election day was this past
tuesday
and we lost uh we didn't do particularly
well
um particularly where we started um
which was as a frontrunner
and it stings it sucks we will
do postmortems in monday morning
quarterback this whole thing many times
i'll get we'll get yang back on here to
talk about it um
but right now he just i think he frankly
needs a vacation and some sleep
um but i want to say this because a lot
of you have been listening to this
podcast i'm sure you've known about the
mayor's race and
have supported and contributed many of
you volunteered and came out to new york
and knocked on doors and
i just want to say y'all are not the
reason
we lost we didn't lose because we didn't
knock enough doors we didn't lose
because
of that article or that tweet or that
moment
that's elections are big picture things
y'all they're not
they're not small picture things um the
reason
we lost this race is because when we
entered
we thought this race and it was it was
all about covid recovery
reopening the economy it was cold it was
dark outside we had no vaccine
businesses were closed and cash relief
our bread and butter when andrew's stand
forward humanity forward and stood for
was number one and then over the course
of the race
the economy opened up the vaccine got
out got delivered distributed
um our schools reopened
the weather warmed up and then crime
went up and it became a crime race
and um when there's a crime epidemic
and you're running as an outsider with
no formal government experience
uh your lane gets pretty thin pretty
quickly and i think at times maybe lost
our way trying to find it but
uh the reality was it was um a tougher
race for
andrew in particular when that's the
dynamic and that sucks
um but i want to say and i think it's
important to say
we ran for president and for mayor
because we
wanted to rewrite the rules we wanted to
legitimize this movement
um and make an economy and society
that values people and
we've only been added a couple years um
and we've made tremendous
strides and we're not going anywhere
like this is just
a hiccup frankly um and it stings
and it's a big deal i'm not trying to
belittle it but um
our best days are ahead of us this
movement andrew yang is not going
anywhere i think you all know that
um but from the bottom of my heart um
for those of you that did help
thank you don't blame yourself or don't
blame others or don't look back and try
monday morning quarterback this thing
it's a big picture
situation and i'm look i'm i don't know
about y'all i'm i'm a religious guy and
this is god's plan um sometimes you just
gotta
stop trying to control everything and uh
believe in the higher power believe
you're doing what's what feels right in
your gut
so a day of
reflection for us i'm recording this a
day after elections that's never
a fun day if you didn't win that race um
but uh they still don't have the final
results um so they'll be calculating
those but um
so we'll know a little more as we go but
anyway guys i love you
we're gonna go back to regular
programming and it's regular as if it's
not good it's awesome
um i've got a conversation here today on
the future of purple states with a guy
named rob
rob richardson um who is
i mean what hasn't this guy done he's
the founder of disrupt art and
disruption now but he's
uh from cincinnati he's run for office
multiple times he has a radio show he's
doing some amazing things at communities
one of my favorite conversations we had
um and helped me get my mind off the new
york city mayor's race for a bit
so anyway um we'll be back to talk more
politics there's gonna be a lot
more new things coming down pike for
yang speaks that's probably the silver
lining here for you listeners is that
this podcast is gonna get good again or
even better
again um so get excited for that
um over the next coming weeks but for
now rob richardson joins jake speaks
right now
[Music]
all right it is my privilege to welcome
someone
who now that i've like i call
professionally stalked online and gotten
to see
the accomplishments i've i'm looking up
to you um
so i'm grateful to welcome rob
richardson
to yang speak to talk about the future
of he's the founder of disrupt art
and disruption now one of the most
interesting people on the cutting edge
of what we're talking about on social
impact
and frankly the future of art in many
ways rob
welcome to the show man how are you hey
it's good to be here zach how are you
man
i'm good man i was just telling um off
off the air before we started out
jealous of your your brick background i
got to work on that
but so um so rob tell us um
let's start with start with you bit um
your background i mean you've been
basically everything you've done is
touch art
business faith politics media activism
uh tell us your story i feel like your
background is
uh frankly one of a kind to be honest
with you well thank you for that so my
um
my story i always start with how i got
interested in wanting to
have impact and it's because i i've had
so many opportunities but i also
know what it's like to be judged
or limited because of your past so i
i struggled in school a lot initially
in uh elementary until about the eighth
grade
i was in uh learning disability classes
i have adhd i don't
think just it's really a learning
difference but
me too but mine wasn't diagnosed yeah
there you go
but back then when they diagnosed it uh
they diagnosed it as a learning
disability in the correct term it's
really a learning difference because
uh it's just how one learns but you know
people didn't know that
so they would put like kids would know
when they would be when they were being
put in their classes
they were different or they weren't
smart and so that that that those
labels began to affect you and it
definitely i know it affected my
thinking and how i thought about myself
but i reached the point it was towards
the end of the eighth grade i remember
it well
i remember the moment and i told my
teacher look
i believe that i can achieve more i want
to i want to
start preparing for college take
advanced classes and do whatever i need
to do to catch up
because to that point i'd been in a lot
of these classes and they weren't
challenging like they should be
right and i knew i could do more and you
grown up in ohio where did you grow up
cincinnati ohio yeah ohio and so zach i
remember this
i still remember this conversation like
it was yesterday zach i had a
conversation with my teacher
this white eye 8th grade kid telling her
all these things that
he wants to do and she looked at me the
dead series faced zach and was like well
look
um college is not meant for everybody
and uh and and uh i i i hate to have to
tell you this but that's not something
that
you're you're going to be able to do
like that's not in your future
and i'm like okay and i'm literally
crying like
so so and crying both of disappointment
and probably rage all at the same time
so i
i go back and have a much better
conversation with my mother
and these words still stick with me to
this day she said look rob
you don't have to be defined by anyone's
low or narrow expectations of you
you define yourself for yourself by
yourself
uh so i took those words to heart and
you know despite what that teacher said
some of my counselors said
although all those folks um i moved
forward and so i did
end up going not only going to college i
i graduated in
electrical engineering moved on to go to
law school
and then got a chance to come back and
actually serve my alma mater and be the
youngest chairman in its history
but i know that that story turns out
differently for a whole lot of people so
why i've done everything that i have
done and will do
is because i don't think people should
be defined uh
by their past or their or their or their
current situation
i want them to fight that and really
disrupt the narratives and the
constructs that are put in front of
people that's that's
why i believe in disruption in that way
not to disrupt for the sake of
disrupting but really disrupting to
empower
uh so that's been what's at the heart of
driving me
when you were that age making was there
a role model in your life
or someone you were aspiring to and that
could have been a celebrity to a parent
like any
or brother you know whoever it is or
friend like was there someone
where you saw like a model of success or
were you truly trailblazing and what you
thought would be
productive for where you wanted well i
mean i have my parents
again i have i have good parents that
where my mother
uh was an entrepreneur who who uh
started her own business learning from
her
her father uh who started his own
business he was he was actually pretty
old he was born in 1902 my grandfather
never got a chance to
really know him well he died when i was
about three but um
he has lots of interesting stories but
one is that he he was actually a chef
for uh many people during the great
depression and so
um and so she really and he had lots of
kids so my mother was a later stage kid
he had but like
um she learned from him that
entrepreneurial spirit and carried that
and started a restaurant
that didn't that didn't succeed uh for a
lot of reasons didn't have adequate
capital but uh she found her way back
and went back to work paid back every
single bill never even defaulted on the
loan
and um you know that was that that just
spirit and that
that that level of resistance and
resilience
uh inspired me and then my dad is a
union leader
um and seeing him day in and day out and
really his experience of
serving and fighting for others and
seeing that i mean both of those things
inspired me and i wanted to you know i
just got just it just the light bulb
went off i said okay i understand
things need to get serious and i need to
start preparing for college and i wanted
to just be serious and it just
it just it clicked for me at that point
and i was behind i will tell you i was
behind but
that experience of having i had to catch
up most of all of high school
but once i got to engineering and
i still wasn't where some of the other
kids were because they had been
preparing longer but i had the grit
and so when they first got there when
they got their first d on something they
just had a mental breakdown
everybody was they wanted to quit like
i'm like hell i mean just hey figure it
out i've had to
learn to adjust to to working hard so uh
i think that i know that experience of
having to go through that resistance
made me a better student and
ultimately likely a better leader and a
better person
i'm sure man i love it's funny sometimes
when you're growing up um there's
certain people end up with a chip on
their shoulder and sometimes it's real
and sometimes it's made up but usually
the chip on the shoulder is a good thing
keeps you humble and hungry if you will
um so you end up to graduate you get the
dream of going to college then a
master's or law degree
um and then you're back at the
university
you end up in politics where does this
journey keep going
really in college i think is where i got
the second like the light bulb that
really said i really want to
to be in public service uh i started the
first college chapter of the uh
of the naacp in like our local area and
the tri-state as we call it because it's
like ohio kentucky and indiana
so i started the first college chapter
at that time
and it was significant because of things
that were going on
at that time the city of cincinnati
uh was then was was essentially where
uh minneapolis is right now in many
other cities we had
uh a lot of struggles with our police
force i think
if i remember the na the the the stat
correctly it was 15
in custody deaths of black men with
police like in a few
in a few years and the um
so you had those things going on so that
activism was very
it was just a part of my experience
because it was part of what i was going
through
not not naturally it living it in the
city of cincinnati
right uh with the police force that had
lots of systemic problems
and and so that experience informed me
to really want to get involved i went to
naacp convention saul
you know just kind of got inspired and
said i really want to i want to i want
to i want to
organize and help change uh help change
the laws help change society as much as
i can so
that's why even when i was in
engineering i knew i was going to go to
law school
and my experience there kind of informed
me now fast forward
ran the naacp for four years there and
then i ran for student body president
as i was running for student body
president
an officer shot and killed uh a teenager
his name was timothy thomas uh in in in
his crime
was parking tickets and he was killed
[ __ ] he was killed unarmed and um
and that that sparked protests that
turned to demonstrations that turned
all-out rights
um and and the city had to be shut down
all of this while i'm literally in the
middle of running for
student body president so the naacp
nationally comes in
cnn comes in so i'm like on the platform
i was already doing these things and
that
just helped helped me even more kind of
launch
the things i was doing and i i i ran
away with the student by presidency and
one
so i got the false belief that when i
ran for office it was going to be that
way too
because my first experience went that
way but all those experiences happened
so that informed
you know what my perspective of what i
wanted to do and get involved with
public policy when something becomes an
issue let's call it black lives matter
the movement george floyd right there
right
um you start off with the the outrage
and the general consensus like yes this
is a problem
um and then it starts once you start to
get tactical it starts to get
politicized right and you live in a
purple state and you see it
um and i don't know if i call this
purple anymore
that's true but that's aspirational yes
but hopefully
yeah maybe like
um look i mean i think a lot of it of
course i think the republicans are
better at this than democrats in many
ways in terms of finding that wedge
issue
um but we're both guilty of um
politicizing everything
you know in your i just was so curious
about this um
andrew and i did an episode after george
floyd shootings like what can we do like
like solutions wise um but now that from
your perspective both from the naacp
in college or with the student body and
then running for office during when
these these issues are front and center
let's say you are in charge um
what do you think this actual tangible
solutions are and then so like there's
one that's right aspirational and then
what's like realistic
i'd love your thoughts on either well
that's a there's so many questions
packed in there
if i can very quickly when we talk about
uh framing the issues what what the
what the right does that is dangerous
and more effective
is they know how to pull emotionally
they know how to target people
emotionally
and do so in a way that has hardly
anything to do with the issues right
they just they just target they know how
to target certain emotions critical race
theory all this nonsense they're doing
there like they know what they're doing
they know who they're targeting and they
know how to message and stay disciplined
on
a discipline on that what um many
progressive democrats would ever want to
call ourselves here
um don't do is there's not there's not
necessarily that understanding of the
other side and how powerful that is
they have a propaganda machine and we
have to understand that that's what it
is and we tackle it as such i just i
think that's
fundamentally so important because we
because there's not there
both sides politicize things but one
side
does it in a way that promotes
propaganda and i think is very very
very very dangerous for democracy so i
just have to say that the expression
someone told me we were running for
office was that
democrats fall in love republicans fall
in line
and uh it's true but what can be done
and that folks should do to be
progressive is know how to
understand how the other side and what
they're doing know how to
speak from uh from a framing that that
frames things in an emotional way
and what we tend to do is um you know we
sometimes frame things in a way that's
not very helpful but
we allow the right to do that the best
example i can think of is this whole
defund the police
yeah of course horrible frame like i i
got friends that are
that that tell me the frame people need
to do it i think some of it is
they're in a twitter universe where that
plays well nowhere else
no way well literally nowhere nowhere
but
what what what what democrats do that
are running for office
is they allow then the republicans to
frame that issue with they want to
defund the police they want to defund
the police
this is coming from activists online and
i'm not i'm not i'm not faulting
activists this is what activists do
their goal is to push the edge
but what but what democrats should do is
okay when that issue comes up you can't
just fumble over yourself and say
i'm not for defunding the police then
what are you for and you mumble over you
should have you should be very
you should be very very clear what
you're for like i am for accountability
i am not for uh off the problem is bad
officers are not held accountable
and i'll make sure that that bad
officers are held accountable
that officers that kill people when they
shouldn't need to go to jail
and i am for that i don't know what my
opponent is for maybe he believes that
we should have bad officers but there
are there are some uh industries that
can't have bad apples you can't
we we don't accept like i think chris
rock said this we don't accept like
uh a bad pilot like okay yeah we got a
bad pilot like
this is a few bad apples and it just
kill like 500 people want to fly who
cares like
it's just a few bad apples there are
some industries right now
that can't have bad apples
and being an officer is one of those
industries now i believe officers should
be paid more
but i also believe they need higher
accountability doesn't mean
that doesn't mean we need more officers
either by the way doesn't mean you are
any doesn't mean
we need to spend more money on getting
more officers it means we need to
pay officers more have better trained
officers
to have a better process of picking the
officers that we choose so let me get
back to the question if i have solutions
immunity right qualified immunity yeah
the cops can
essentially that easily get away with
murder zero like there's no
there is no justification for that uh
if i think one of the things if that
happens if you can be held personally
liable
when you are reckless with uh someone's
life
or your your the the taxpayer shouldn't
always have to be the ones picking up
the officer makes not that makes a
mistake when an officer shouldn't be an
officer when you know these officers
should not be here so
i mean that's one thing qualified
immunity as from federal level
everywhere there's no reason
why that should be there i am a strong
supporter of unions
uh i believe that they that that the fop
can still have some rights to negotiate
it's gone too far though they have too
much power and
it has gotten to the point where people
they're going to eventually lose power
this happened to a lot of different
unions when you get to a point where you
abuse the
uh the power that oh you've been losing
left and right right policing it seems
like
right but like policing is is they have
too much power so
uh cities need to start using their
powers instead of
and not and sometimes an arbitration
actually fight this is very hard to do
i i i've run for municipal politics i
have no illusions about this extremely
hard to do it's extremely hard
in a local city yes the police is your
best friend
yeah and they need to be but the
relationship can't be
that the police have that the police
when you talk about the police union
that you have to do everything that they
say i agree with that i'm not saying i'm
not saying that's even bad
but it's practically very very very hard
i'm not saying this is easy
the grass people on the ground are going
to have to come up with solutions too so
what i think is going to have to happen
is so if i was in charge of
if i was in charge of an organization
let's say because it's going to have to
happen at some federal level but it's
going to have to
happen a lot at the local level there
needs to be some specific issues and
actually go after
things at the local level so there are a
lot of cities that allow you to have
i don't know i don't know how new york
works but cincinnati has charters so you
can make
amendments within the city uh and how
the structure of the government by
presenting it it's a direct
form of government and there's a lot of
cities like that so if
you know so i would do what if you know
what the uh what is that organization
that the koch brothers started
uh anyway when it comes comes to me
they'll come but what they did is they
were really strategic they started in
cities and figure out what
legislation do we need to pass that are
in the interests of our constituents so
they have these crazy gut laws that you
know they figure out a way oh let's
bring a gun to a nursery that's got to
happen everywhere oh stand your ground
in the middle of street everybody can be
the wild wild west so because this is
what the nra wants
but they have a the or we want to go
after unions so let's go let's let's
have
laws pass so americans for prosperity
and gator institute are kind of that's
it
americans are for prosperity so and
there's probably stuff we they're doing
we don't know about but i agree with you
they they do this
fear play and if you're not paying
attention
like if you're just a casual because
then you and i and
andrew and anybody who's on twitter with
the blue check so stuff they're all
hyper focused but if you're a casual
person
you're like you're not paying attention
you're like well crime's up cause i'm
seeing all these stories on crime
and i'm seeing the people i thought i
liked on the left or the democrats are
either saying to fund the police or
a version of it or stumbling over it and
you're scared
and that's not necessarily fair um that
they should be scared whether hyped up
but i think that's the reality that we
as democrats or anyone that's actually
trying to fix something
needs a grapple with we need to have the
americans prosperity approach
to doing this on the other side so let's
get smart because what
democrats overall a few things that i
know this from running
get really excited about the big sexy
races running for
president congress senate yay that's not
even where most of the money is spent or
the action happens so there needs to be
a thought process for the long term
versus just short term reacting to who's
in office
so an approach should be what type of
legislation do we need to pass
at local levels to really have
substantial changes
to have more accountability and more
equity within our criminal justice
system and within the police force
and so there are ways do we do we look
at qualified immunity on local levels do
we look at making sure that we
reign in the power of of the fop
if it's out of control in certain areas
how do we do that and do we do it by
so do we do it by state law and we and
we press there
and we create model legislation that's
what we should do and get then we get
activists also on the ground
to work with us and and at least go on a
on one accord and page like our goal is
not to defund the police our goal is to
have police accountability our goal is
to make sure that the community can
trust the police
because if they can't nothing can happen
i mean so
um you you we have to have the approach
on not just
everything being solved in the
president's office and not
and not giving all of our money all of
our time all of our focus there
there has to be some local uh focus and
i would probably i would
choose some target cities and target
areas uh
to build from have some success have
some actual success because success
breeds success
and then grow from there i agree so one
of the things when i um when running got
to work with the dnc
and to their credit they have new they
had new leadership when i got there and
they were starting a whole bunch of new
things but i guess
what they were saying was that in 2006
2000
basically before or right before and
then during obama's presidency
it wasn't very strategic because they
had their superstar
they could just you know throw obama in
a room and raise a million bucks and
that it was like kind of structured
around the the celebrity of politics um
and it brushed over a lot of um
thing like they're blocking and tackling
and needed to be done which is these
local these city council races the court
seating the coin appointments
um so 100 agreed with you so you just
ran for
ohio treasurer i think was the most
recent one did you
get caught in this where it's like i got
i'm running against someone on the right
who's got a wedge issue
and i'm stuck here because i need the
far left to turn out
um because they're gonna have the
excitement in this but i also
know this race is going to be one with
moderate voters and casuals right like
where did you get stuck on was there a
wedge issue or something in your race
that you saw and it gets spun and all
these things right
what'd you see so the answer is uh
uh i got myself out of not being stuck
because i tried i was i was going to be
but i didn't because i
i i i'm a why person so one of my
favorite books is by simon sinek start
with why
um yeah it is a great book so everything
i do when i talk about my mission and my
vision i leave with my why
and if it doesn't align my why i'm not
going to do it now it doesn't mean that
you don't figure out how to do it in a
way that's
uh where you can have the most effect
because you never just because you don't
change your y
doesn't mean that you can communicate
your why the same way with this
uh every time with us or that your why
is very good or people care about it you
know if you're right
i want to be in power it's not always
just so compelling that's not really why
that's what you want
most people don't have a why which is a
big problem in politics getting to your
question
um another way to state a why for the
political
uh nerds and everyone is what is a line
from lyndon johnson
he said what convinces is conviction
people have to believe what you believe
that you're putting forward so i i
authenticity
that is my measure for how i articulate
uh issues not trying to figure out
how do i say it in the most moderate way
because people won't believe you anyway
right and that's the problem democrats
have trying to figure out how to say and
you notice people on the right never do
that so
i actually disagree with the premise
like whether people say they're moderate
like here's what you got to do you have
some things you have to have a core
conviction about
some things like everything in
moderation
even moderation some things right
right some things people have to know
that this is what
i am willing to fight for so an issue
that came out
because people just don't believe you
otherwise and you know
and frankly republicans are better at
being propaganda than playing lies
so democrats should be i'm not saying
they they choose every single issue and
out here but there's got to be some
issues
something that you have to say this is
my non-negotiable
at least one or two and so i had two
right i had two
one was criminal justice not surprising
i actually got endorsed by the
fop statewide um yeah uh
but uh but uh one issue that came up was
uh there was a uh statewide issue on
criminal justice reform
and it and it um it made a lot of
felonies
for uh drug possession into misdemeanors
and focus a lot more on
uh treatment than uh locking folks up
it's one of my fundamental beliefs right
right
and the way it was spun though when it
was spotted a whole nother way that
we're going to lock allow criminals and
this and that
oh yeah the right can take that little
interest in a mile right very quickly
and they did
they did i i supported it actually the
gubernatorial candidate richard cordray
supported it at that time too
and um and so but many others didn't did
not because they were scared or scared
of the polling
and my opponent tried to use it against
me and you know i remember this he kind
of well you know
my opponent wants to use the
constitutional amendment that's not what
it's for
it shouldn't be done i said i said i
agree we should legislators should do
that you're in office why don't you
change it oh
that's right you don't want to this is
the problem we have people that don't
want to actually approve the issue they
just like to point out problems
like i will not be that type of leader i
want to solve like that worked if i got
a chance to talk to people
i converted a lot of republicans got
over two million votes that's how
democrats have they have to learn how to
frame issues
in a way that people understand um and
then so what i talk about and
then i talked about going after uh
pharmaceutical companies i talked about
that a lot
in my um in my in my pitch and i was
running for treasure and i just said i'm
gonna use the power of the treasurer
to make sure that we and i talked about
some specific ways i was gonna do that
and we have a
problem with uh opioids like everyone
else does but it's really bad in ohio
but framing issues in a way
that people can understand what you're
fighting for because the republicans may
not agree with me or some on everything
but
a lot of people had issues with opioids
a lot of people do not like
pharmaceutical companies
but i get them focused on that um they
can understand where i'm coming from
from that perspective
so um and then i try where you can be
moderate
you should be like show people that
you're reasonable in some ways like
everything doesn't have to be
all the way to the edge on everything
but you do have to have some
core convictions and beliefs and you
have to be willing to articulate it
i think one of the issues we ran across
with this is that uh the governor
everyone paid attention to the
governor's race that's one two trump
really turned down voters
and and he got them to focus on an issue
that nothing to do with ohio what do you
think
the number one issue for the first time
republican voters in ohio was in 2018
what do you think it was i'm gonna guess
either we were still talking about
building the wall or we're talking about
obamacare
like what we're it's close close the the
the item of that moment if you remember
was uh the central america the central
american invasion remember people from
central america oh yeah
what do they call it caravan right yeah
the caravan the caribbean the caravan i
care about me people they got them
looking over here and they're like
caravan caravan
we're in ohio he's not gonna come up
here like
have you looked around like this is ohio
but that became the central issue and
again they know what they're doing so
democrats have to be
and so when this issue when we have
issues that really motivate
the people that are in our base we have
to own some of them otherwise we can't
win
like it has to come like we have to
engage our base we can't always hope for
uh you know obama somebody that walks on
water politically or
or or we have the devil in office like
those
that we seem to be at our best when that
happens but we need to be able to win
the close and the boring and the regular
races too
you got to have an angie used to say you
know i'd go to parts of ohio or
michigan wisconsin and say i'm a
democrat and they think it's a you know
four-letter word i think it's the cringe
and it's um
and there's a whole bunch of reasons for
it not all fair but the republicans are
excellent at finding wedge issues and
what they're
what does that mean is like every time
democrats make a mistake
i mean any of them from the squad to
schumer
and pelosi um they find it they cut it
they print it on fox news they crank it
through right-wing
media radio and they create let me put
it everywhere until the left-wing press
is covering a bit because it's
fascinating um
and it's not where most of the country
stands it's not where most democrats
stand most time
um we have this i'm curious thoughts we
have this
i think it's fundamentally ridiculous
that
we somehow now expect everyone to agree
on everything
you know like what name one human being
where you agree with everything they do
or
say or believe this is not true and it's
a sign of some sort of mental maturity
where you can say well i'm
looking more conservative on this and a
little more liberal on these and
these are my non-negotiables and this
like i'm not going to mad over that like
um did you find my question about the
media where i'm going here is like did
you find the media pressuring you to be
black and white on certain things where
it's like hey where do you stand on this
and then
you know i was like oh you know if we
found that a lot we're like you know
andrew
could care less about xyz issue in the
sense that
it's not quarter's platform and doesn't
think it's he's not why he's running
but you get caught up in that gotcha
game or in the fight itself did you have
you know things like that yeah of course
and
it's challenging because you it is a
game it is a game you have to learn how
to play to win it's just the truth
and in the media the media's goal
generally you know there are some great
journalists
but generally the goal is to get clicks
and to make money so generating
headlines is all that matters and and
back to my earlier point about
propaganda
though this is specifically true with
the right like they frame people as
angels and devils like we don't even
know why these people are good they're
just good people you're just supposed to
trust them
we don't know why these people are
devils but they're devils and they're
and you just have to know that
and so you know fox news and many others
the biggest they have become
you get better contacts and stories from
disney than you do from fox
right fox makes up stories and
propaganda based upon nothing
right and and there's a lot of
right-wing media because they know how
to trigger their people
the left has we have our own issues too
you talk about cancel culture that's
some in the left on line two i really
think
the issue here is that so that social
media
has been um started off great but it's
been it's been weaponized now in a way
that yeah it's been weaponized in a way
that people can believe their own
alternate realities and it is their
realities
and once some once the human brain makes
up its mind it's very difficult to
change that so i believe that what we
have to do
to avoid i think overall democrats
people that care about democracy
need to be spending a lot more time
understanding how powerful propaganda is
and spend a lot more money time
resources uh
addressing propaganda because this is
propaganda and making sure that we are
uh
we're constantly trying to convert the
people we can there's a lot of people we
can't convert
but all we need to do is convert a small
amount of people just to get them to
understand that this propaganda is being
used and weaponized against them
and then we can bring them back i mean
it's been shown that can work but i
don't i still think
democrats and people that didn't like
what the former
the the former uh occupant of the white
house was doing don't even want to say
his name
i think they got too focused and saying
we beat him we win nice no
like he was a warning sign and things
can get worse like think if someone was
smarter than him
they could have done a whole lot of
damage you should be looking like yang
we ran on this a lot like trump is a
symptom he is not the core problem he's
a problem right now but he's a
reflective of a symptom
and you know i'm i'm wondering um
to me it always seems like democrats
just seem to find their own wedge issues
um and pick them better than it's not
that hard like it's it's the the wedge
issues
there they exist i mean it's i mean they
and then i actually think democrats need
to pass
stuff too and be so i i tell folks so if
you look at what's going on here and we
got
one person holding up the whole two i
guess in a way
and i don't understand the strategy but
when you
but then we'll talk about things to get
people riled up we'll talk about things
we're doing with race whatever so on and
so forth so
and then we won't necessarily pass
anything to solve these issues
that causes two problems one the
rhetoric that's used
is used to get the other side riled up
as we've said a lot today it doesn't
take that much
and they can use that and so that's one
the second
is that it depresses your base and
people that
so you need to when we get in office we
need to pass stuff
what the best way to convince the best
way to convince the public is to pass it
case in point obamacare it's popular now
it wasn't before
pass the bills like i don't understand
anything i don't i don't see any
advantage to
um to trying to placate to what
republicans want
when they show you they have no interest
in good faith negotiations if it was
there fine
it hasn't been there in 15 years so what
we have to do right now
is pa pass the bill to protect people's
right to vote
like this is how to pass a bill uh to
make sure that we improve our
infrastructure and create jobs
do these things and i guarantee you
democrats will win more but if we get in
office and we don't
do stuff hard to argue that
democrats should be elected specifically
when you can't pass the things that you
say that you were going to pass or that
you care about
past things that's that's what you
should do get stuff done
[Music]
gsd
okay if you've been listening to this
podcast you've heard andrew
and myself talk about our helix
mattresses and helix has started a new
company called all form they've left the
bedroom
and started making sofas and they are
incredibly comfortable they look good
they're durable
they're easy to assemble i freaking love
this thing so you go online
similar to helix you take a little it's
not a quiz if you will but you kind of
customize what you want pick the leg
color pick the sofa color
get shape size and it gets shipped to
you like your mattress
and it's so easy to assemble i am
terrible at assembling things and it
fit like a glove just snapped into place
it looks awesome and what i love about
this thing guys
you can get food all over it and does
not stain my mom works for a high-end
realtor and she read all the product
descriptions she's like this is a
high-end sofa
and it is nowhere near the price of what
traditional furniture stores will charge
you and if you don't like it
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it it's more than three freaking
months
it's freaking awesome and just like
helix they'll pick it up for you and get
rid of it if you don't like it so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
yang and all form right now is offering
20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
yang check it out now allform.com
so i want to talk a little bit more
about what you're you're doing because i
think
um a lot of these issues we're talking
about um
like the broken system broken politics
the broken media
um i think a lot can be fixed with
education
um i know that sounds like a fun
catch-all but um i think the root of
most of our problems is
look you don't educate your populace you
don't give people access to good
education
um starts up to start things things
start to fritz
um and it's tough to expect people to
think logically when they're both
poor and uneducated right um and that's
that's frustrating um
well i'm gonna challenge that statement
a little bit i think that's kind of true
but i also think there's some
i mean the data shows that people are
people are generally
irrational right it's it's our deep yeah
you can be extremely educated
because i found some very smart educated
people
people just get into their zones into
their and it shuts off and they just
shut down and shut off so
a lot of dumb smart people yeah yeah
there's a whole bunch of people and i
think so
sadly if i can i would
i would i would i put these things in
three different buckets
right the power to change comes with
protests because you have to fight back
in order to make things happen
the protest doesn't matter until you
actually have policy
so that's to be tied to policy but you
also can't sustain policy
and protest won't matter unless you
actually have power
right and so like i think communities
have to have to
have to have to have to join together to
get more power
it comes with education because you need
education as a basis layer so education
has
to be equitable and there needs to be
opportunities and i can have a whole
lot so i i agree with you that education
is very important
i just have a different reason for it
like i don't think people are
necessarily convinced
because they have education um
doesn't mean they're going to be
rational or not no i mean what happens
and you're right
right i mean people people tend to be
well the greatest indicator of someone
voting for
uh that last person in office is who
clearly was
racist or or at least using racist
propaganda and doing things as divisive
as possible
saying misogynistic thing so you pick
your reasons for for not liking him
there's a whole lot of reason not to
like him
but the single biggest indicator was
people living in non-diverse communities
that that was it so like it's hard
harder to hate up close
right so oh my gosh yes right so like
it's you can
it's easy to believe stereotypes but
when you actually get to know people
it's a lot harder um so we have to
figure out how do we get more how do we
get
how do we get more opportunities to
connect people
how do we connect rural communities and
urban communities in a way that's
meaningful
how do we how do we i think how do we
expand
access to uh infrastructure in terms of
not only
uh hopefully having uh uh you know
high-speed rail that connects us in
different ways but also infrastructure
for the 21st century
building out uh wi-fi and uh making sure
that we that folks have the the
broadband
support in all their communities like
that i think doing that thing and
connecting people more the more people
can be isolated
you can give them all the education in
the world the more people are isolated
and they're in their corners the harder
it is i was working in
um in brooklyn um at a a
a lower income school and a lot of the
kids did not seem to have
um kind of to your point like the why
they're in school
like they're like learning math but why
like what is this for
um just so i get an a on a test for what
to go to college that seems unattainable
um are you i mean i'm oversimplifying it
but that uh but
that's very important you're right i
mean there's there's not a practical
application they're like what is this
what does this matter in my life so we
started doing business competitions in
these schools or bringing the kids to
the office
it was like shark tank light where the
kids would create a new shoe for nike or
something like that
um and the biggest thing we found was
that the kids are like
they changed their their their
trajectory in their mind they're like
well this is why math matters because
when lebron james or seth curry whoever
you know nicki minaj is wearing those
shoes or doing her music video
she's getting paid for that someone's
running their numbers someone's
designing the set there's all these
different things um
but i um i haven't figured out
um like our org is growing it's great i
do think this is like a core to what's
missing education that like active
relevant learning piece but i don't know
how to do it at scale
um in that um so i'm curious your
thoughts on
um how to get i know you've done a lot
of work with entities and businesses but
how to get
the kids that need this access and
frankly if they had the access to
a direct path to nike would be kicking
ass at that firm they would kill to have
these kids ideas in many ways um
but aren't getting it and what i mean um
it starts with wi-fi we're talking about
but things you've seen and maybe even
tell about some of the work you're doing
to kind of break those barriers i think
it's interesting
at scale is really tough um
it it's it's it's going to be local
solutions in areas because
you have to be proximate to the area or
to the problem to really have
a long-term impact um i don't have the
answer to be
to be scalable i i yeah but but i do
know
that there are some things that have to
happen for it to work the things you're
talking about
the uh connecting uh learning to
to things that that kids understand and
can see and touch
uh really providing education that is
not just about
you know learning abstract points in
history
or pure memorization which i think is
almost a waste of a waste of our time
uh i don't think that's what should be
done uh i do think there needs to be a
lot more on how do we how do we get
how do we teach them heck things they
can like editing
um uh how to code for financial and
beyond that
but before you get to that critical
thinking put them in situations about
yeah in a way that is uh real and and
and applicable like you did like if you
had a shark tank thing and you made it
apply
and they got a chance to do that the
folks got a chance to actually do
internships i've found
if we can get more opportunities for uh
expert
experiential experiences where people
can actually go and have jobs
and and work with uh entrepreneurs
people in corporate america and you have
kids that normally wouldn't see that
they get that opportunity
those things change perspectives i mean
it starts with people changing
perspectives about what's possible
um and it has to be done at the local
level like i scaling it
i i don't know fully i just have an idea
of what has to happen
at local levels one of my biggest fears
right now is
the world is changing faster than it
ever has the world's always been changed
but now we're seeing that change
accelerate
and absolutely you're starting to see
game-changing technologies and they're
going to hit us faster so i think the
blockchain
um is one like massive example i think
deep fakes i think 3d printing there's
some things that are going to start
accelerating and changing everything
um and obviously the internet has done
its number on us
um yep it already has changed how we
think
oh yeah we're like it's over going that
way and all these kids are growing up
i'm addicted to the phones and adults
addictive phones too it's not the kids
fault um
and but my fear is
um so when this happens there's a
massive opportunity we're gonna have a
new market a new economy like all these
things gonna change really fast but um
if it's still the way we are at are now
you're gonna have the
wealthy the elite the powerful the uber
educated are going to have access to
these new changes on the frontier
and who gets left behind the
marginalized communities communities of
color
i mean by the numbers across the board
and so my fear the example is like oh by
blockchain and bitcoin and these
cryptocurrencies are going to
democratize finance and do all these
great things
you're right but there's going to be the
people that actually could use the
democratization
not get access to them um now
to me the simplest way to solve that is
actually your point like let's get wi-fi
everywhere so like the kid is coming
from a rough
like the worst background ever like
theoretically he or she is like
ability to at least have access
hypothetically
to the treasures of the internet and
some of these crazy ideas that are
changing everything um
but that's obviously oversimplification
not the only thing that needs to happen
but thoughts on
[Music]
how we can get the right the communities
that need it would benefit most of it
into
crypto nfts like some of these cutting
edge tech or whatever they may be
when i when i hear all of these uh
politicians and i hear them on the left
and the right
they focus on returning to things as
they were right
make america great again there's you're
conservative or you're rich you've got
something to conserve right right
yeah but a lot of people that are
conserving
uh a past that where america was the
only
dominant superpower where you know if it
was just enough to be
a white man and that's all you need it
to be and you can
use you can hang on to just that feeling
um
or or like we had just everything was
heavy manufacturing
uh that world's not coming back it's
never coming back so
we can't re we we can't we can't
recreate the past but we can build a
better future as you say
and so our our policies need to be
thinking about
what's coming next like you you you
really talked about a lot of it but we
know
i think i think the biggest both threat
and opportunity is artificial
intelligence
uh it's because that that is that it
that is
and is going to rapidly change the the
landscape of work
and so you know the question has to be
what is our policy going to be to deal
with this and
and and to make sure that we are doing
everything possible
to to get our get our citizens ready for
that economy
and that has to be our approach our
approach can't be we we're going to do
what we've done before because ai and
technology are moving things so are
moving so fast
uh that a whole bunch of people will be
displaced i i i'm hopeful that
folks will have will be able we'll
transition into new jobs that happen in
the industrial revolution but what
people don't talk about
is there was a 20 or 30 year period
where people were massively displaced
and it was a horrible time
and so people never talk about they talk
about what happened after we went
through that they
they think about the benefits right they
talk about the benefits
they don't talk about the struggle to
get to the benefits they don't talk
about the fact that when we had all
these robber barons that we were
exploiting kids and that people were
working
like 15 hours a day and people were
dying all the time on the job and they
no one talks about that part right but
but what we had to do to make it better
is we obviously had unions we have
people we had workers fight back we had
child labor laws every day became a
holiday because right massive strikes
people died yeah and we created a
economy that began to address these
concerns took us a long time to do it
uh we can't take that long with
technology because it's gonna move so
much faster
and so we have to be more nimble so it's
not gonna so we have to have
and this is very difficult because often
you have people in government that have
no idea
about technology and so they're creating
policies they have no idea
how to actually move it forward and then
you got a lot of technologists
that some of them are very well-meaning
a lot of them just care about
becoming very very rich right and
nothing wrong with getting
rich i believe in capitalism but i
believe in in having a system that works
for people so
uh why i'm in entrepreneurship right now
and it's not to say i wouldn't get back
into
running public office at some point is
that i believe it's so hard to really
have that impact right now because
people
people's brains are just so shut off
right now i have a lot of people that i
can work with i say the same thing
that i'm saying to you right now as long
as i if i don't say i'm a democrat i'm
working in business people are all for
it like but there's no real right so
like so
my goal is to really uh expand where i
can with entrepreneurship so
uh our platform disrupt art is looking
to use
uh art uh that is aimed towards social
impact so we wanna empower people that
are
in in marginalized communities to be
there they're going to be the feature of
the platform
uh part of the platform is teaching
these artists to become better
entrepreneurs
and we also want partnerships to to
promote uh
art that is about social impact art an
example one of the artists
that we that that that's going to come
up on our platform his name is
uh david bianchi he's a he's a big
well-known actor he's pretty well a
well-known actor spoken spoken word
artist
and he had an nft about george floyd and
gave all the money to that and i think
he made like 20 they made like 20 000
i mean there's a way to connect and
empower the community we want to use the
platform to do that because
the tech the technology is not going
anywhere there are people that
i know you're not one of those people
that say like well we just shouldn't do
these things i hear you
but artificial intelligence is coming
blockchain is here it's it's here
so the the question is how are we going
to use it in a way
that empowers people so i mean my job i
think is to try
is to use is to use my platform and use
the power
to help and empower more people that's
what we are hoping distinguishes disrupt
art
disrupt art.io now from other
other platforms they're about just
selling but we want to actually create a
platform that will have uh events and
accelerators that are helping
these artists but also eventually
entrepreneurs and others use the power
of technology
uh to help transform society
you said a number of things that um you
could probably go a whole bunch of
different ways on this but i think
um one of the things that stuck with me
is that uh
you know i could say the same thing but
if as long as i don't say democrat
republican i can have a rational
conversation as soon as we put
you know it's like root for the yankees
the red sox or i'm buffalo bills fans so
i
you know i don't want to talk to
patriots fans um you know it's like it
doesn't matter what you say and i don't
like it um
and that's what's happened this like
political fandom and it's
one of the reasons i think rob is like
people like you
like throw their hat in the ring into
politics you're like oh this was
terrible i can do way more as an
entrepreneur or way more as a
businessman
in my community um because
it's one of the things andrew and i
struggle with is that both of us
are builders like we looked at running
for president as a like a co-founder
like star like you're the candidate i'm
the ceo whatever and like go let's go
and that was great it worked to a point
but then when you want to win
they want to play ball right and instead
of just being like oh that's a guy's got
a right reason to run and a solid
candidate and that sort of thing and
raise money
but you want to win it's just a
different game and it becomes
it becomes so much more polarizing so
that i think i am
to your point and i think you kind of
alluded this i am really optimistic
i think we are trending in the right way
though yeah oh yeah and it's gonna take
more pain to get where we need to go
but i i agree with you but we can't take
it for like
like the future i say this all the time
as we wrap up i mean the future is not
guaranteed
uh progress is not guaranteed all of it
has to be fought for by people that care
because i am optimistic but i'm also not
naive
like the people that want it more win
and so if you want
a decent society you have to get
involved
both politically and in any way you can
with your platform as a business person
as a media person whatever future's not
guaranteed nothing is you got to fight
for it
we need allies at every aspect of our
economy and society
both from moms and brothers and sisters
to ceos and
c-suite executives um it's and andrew
and i would say
the california's not coming we are the
cavalry no um
that's funny i have a similar say a
statement like you know no
nobody's coming to save us the
superheroes for the comic books
yes and the thing the other key is i
think it's giveaway ends like
for people like yourself and myself in
this fight we need to recognize the ally
when you see them
you know this person zach gromit is not
perfect he's going to say something dumb
i guarantee it either on this podcast or
in the future
and that is not but he is doing his best
to be a freaking ally right and they're
pl
you identify those people like build the
bridge the islands of excellence
whatever you do to work around the
people who are actually working against
you
um and that's hard um particularly how
this you know social media is gonna
fan that flame brother um but um
i am i am appreciative of your work
um and i'm grateful for your time rob so
best
website for you disrupt art dot io
anywhere else yeah
you can disrupt io you can also go to
disruption now you can go to either
website disruptionnow.com
but definitely disrupt art.io i want you
to definitely see the nft platform we're
building and zach i'd love to
talk to you more let's have we gotta
have another conversation i don't know i
guess about you
i'll come we'll come back on your show
um let's do it i uh look i i
thank you thank you for your time keep
fighting the good fight you're a real
life superhero to me i like we've had a
lot of real life superheroes on this
podcast we're trying one of the goals to
talk about the future with people
actually doing the work and shaping the
future so thank you rob
god bless and we'll talk to you soon
appreciate you brother talk soon
[Music]
you